for so long I was having palpitations
high anxiety day and night waking up not
being able to fall asleep waking up all
night to 3:00 in the morning every
single night feeling anxious all day
shaky weak for so long or I would say as
long as I can remember all my adult life
it makes life sad and nothing's fun when
you feel bad and anxious and worried and
stressed and everybody suffers everybody
in my family suffers because mommies
upset or scared or you know can't
tolerate any little annoyance or stress
I couldn't tolerate anything even normal
life I couldn't tolerate so it affected
my whole family and my friends and my
work my sleep improved immediately
before I couldn't relax I couldn't I was
afraid to go to sleep because sleeping
was frightening over the years it just
got worse I couldn't fall asleep
initially then once I would fall asleep
I couldn't stay asleep and when I woke
up I would wake up anxious and sometimes
even panicky and fearful and having bad
dreams but not really remembering just
being afraid yeah
and in heart-pounding
physical symptoms sometimes just getting
up in and running and not even being
aware of it and having a panic attack
during my sleep and then waking up in
the bathroom or in another room and
realizing that I've panicked and gotten
out of bed and it's horrible
after the acupressure I initially I
would feel maybe a little fuzzy and
tired ignition right after leaving but
then the evening and the next day
following I would feel completely
energized and calm no weakness no
sickness no trembling and almost so
relaxed that I didn't even recognize it
I didn't know I would take note and say
this is so different I'm not worrying
about anything
I'm not reacting to anything it's so
unfamiliar because I was that way for so
long yeah definitely after the
treatments I feel that I don't react to
just everyday work stress kids stress
you know timing you know not enough time
in the day I just handle things better I
feel like they're still stressed but I
don't react I just kind of it's like
okay you know something's gone wrong
we're late spilled something I just
before it with everything was drama I
couldn't handle anything the sleep I
sleep if I can get to sleep because I
don't have things to do but when I when
I go to bed I fall asleep within a few
minutes I stay asleep I wake up maybe
once in three weeks where I used to wake
up three or four times a night every
night now I'll wake up once in a while
and not be scared and not be freaking
out no panic attacks just waking up to
use the restroom or something like that
just something normal so completely it's
night and day
my husband's definitely noticed my kids
have noticed they see the changes they
see the changes in the diet and me
coming here and that I'm my husband
knows now that I'm resting because all
of that was disturbing him every time I
got up he got up every time I was in a
panic
it would startle him he didn't know what
was going on and whether I was really
sick or am I having a heart attack he
didn't know either
so it everybody has noticed the change
what it is though he just said keep
going whatever is working keep doing it
just you know whatever it is that you
need to do because nothing else has
worked I've been to every single doctor
there is psychiatrists psychologists
counselors cardiologists hematologists
you name it I've been to them and had
everything checked and they all tell me
that some give me a lot of pills and
tell me if there's lots of things wrong
with me and some just say there's
nothing wrong with you I don't have a
pill for that so at times in my life
I've been on a lot of medication that
didn't help and then there's been times
in my life where I didn't take anything
and was the same my weight was
approximately 185 maybe 190 and I
followed the diet I I wouldn't say it
was easy to lose the weight but once I
got into it and I made small I wasn't
able to change everything initially but
I made small changes and as I was able
to follow the diet I I lost the weight
it wasn't difficult and then I didn't
miss the food I don't miss my potato
chips or anything anymore I don't even
want it when I see it
approximately 138 140 I don't weigh
myself well with an exception of a
little bit of up and down here and there
one or two pounds probably over 40
pounds that will make you feel a lot
better in itself